justin brasier m'a rejoint plateau
bonsoir pense pas de la rédaction de tv
soixante dix huit pour parler d'une
autre formation politique la république
en marche
le parti présidentiel présenté cinq
binômes candidat dans les yvelines quels
étaient les cantons concernés
oui donc vous l'avez dit en seulement
cinq binômes dans les yvelines pour le
parti a l'air au m sur quand même les 21
cantons du département
donc les cantons concernés sont celui de
bonnières-sur-seine mantes-la-jolie
montigny le bretonneux trappe et
versailles rhin des choix qui ont été
faits en fonction aussi des alliances ou
pas qui avait été fait lors des
élections municipales et l'objectif
c'était en tout cas dans les endroits où
il y avait eu des alliances qu'il n'y
ait pas de candidat qui se présente
contre les maires sortants on a présenté
des équipes vraiment sur des cantons que
l'on a estimé délaissé par le
département et quel bilan du coup pour
ce premier tour des élections
départementales alors au niveau des
résultats sur le canton de
bonnières-sur-seine didier dumont et
dorothée rivière obtiennent à 19,94 pour
soi pour sans pardon des voix exprimées
à 12 31% pour alain le cam et khadija
mounib pour le canton de mantes la jolie
pour le canton de montigny le bretonneux
pauline bécamel et que les gorille pape
récolte 17 84 % du suffrage
du côté de canton de trappes aïcha
borgès et christophe but obtenu 9,57 %
des votes et puis ou canton de
versailles laurent de bastard et anne
france simon finissent deuxièmes de ce
premier tour avec 19 points 0 8% des
voix
c'est le seul binôme lrm à se maintenir
au second tour de ces élections dans les
yvelines
la réaction de la candidate on
s'attendait pas forcément à être au
second tour et en même temps quand ça
arrive c'est vrai qu'on est talonné par
les autres mais j'en suis quand même pas
si sûr triste que ça voilà je me dis bah
oui c'est c'est justice à la parce qu'on
a beaucoup travaillé là on va avoir une
semaine pour essayer de convaincre les
les électeurs qui n'ont pas voté pour
nous évidemment mais surtout aussi
beaucoup les abstentionnistes au second
tour ils feront face au duo d'ensemble
pour les yvelines composé de claire
chagnaud forains et olivier
l'afer qui sont en tête avec 45,2 30%
des bois merci justin pour toutes ces
informations